[Music]
we're going live to the house of commons
for uh prime minister's questions
uh prime minister a lot on his agenda
today and after prime minister's
questions there will be a minute silence
followed by half an hour of tributes to
james brokenshire the former
secretary who died of cancer
uh recently just uh
seeing now um adap
the climate change envoy to the cop
meeting in two weeks time uh finishing
up uh answering questions
uh and uh
beth i mean it has to be said
the government's announcements on
reaching that zero yesterday
there's a pathway to get it but the
question about how it's uh funded and
the reliability of the technology and
how much that will cost and how much it
will cost the taxpayer are obviously
very live questions but it runs to 2050
so there's a road map if you like but
the detail about how it actually happens
and the cost to the taxpayer are still
huge questions with obviously the
chancellor and the treasury uh also
releasing a document which quite
explicitly said that you might have to
well let's see if this comes up prime
minister's question is getting underway
celine hoyle the speaker
setting the ball rolling
on parliament live tv we now start with
questions prime minister rachel maskel
thank you mr speaker number one please
prime minister uh mr speaker this
morning i had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others in addition to my
duties in this house i shall have
further such meetings later today
david amos and james brokenshire were
both tragically taken from us both
served this place with integrity and
served their constituents well and as we
offer our heartfelt love and prayers to
their families their families have
offered us a new path to a new politics
built on kindness and love
mr speaker sarah everard and claudia
lawrence were both from york
and right now women are feeling unsafe
many women are unsafe and the very
people that should be protecting us are
telling us to engage with potential
perpetrators to identify them to flag
down a bus or to know the laws of arrest
better
confidence in the police has taken its
toll but as women we are confident and
determined to change this to every girl
and every woman can live at home without
fear can go to school or work without
harassment can go online without
objectification
and can walk our streets safely again
what steps will the prime minister take
to ensure women with lived experience
can lead on this work and by when
prime minister
i i thank her very much for her question
and she raises a most important issue mr
speaker one of the most important that
this country faces and i want all
people in this country particularly
women to feel confident in our police
force and i believe that they can and
that they should and what we're doing
now to make sure that women in
particular feel safe at night is we're
investing in safer streets in better
street lighting in more
cctv but what we also have to do mr
speakers i think the whole house
understands is ensure we deal with the
systemic problems in the criminal
justice
system uh to ensure that bit that men
and i'm afraid it is almost always men
get prosecuted for rape and for crimes
of serious sexual and domestic violence
uh in the way that they should and that
we secure the convictions that we should
mr speaker and that when we secure those
convictions those individuals get the
tough sentencing that they deserve mr
speaker and that's what this side of the
house believes in
thank you mr speaker having a
prematurely born child in neonatal
intensive care means that for families
every day can be a struggle practically
financially and emotionally trying to
continue with life as normal whilst
wrapped with worry and a guilt that
simply never leaves you is just not
possible that's why the prime minister's
commitment to deliver new nades will
even pay for parents in this situation
is so important so the prime minister
meet with me to discuss how quickly we
can put this through parliament so
parents are getting this support as
quickly as possible
prime minister mr speaker i'll make sure
that my right honourable friend my
honorable friend has the relevant
meeting as fast as we can
we can organize it and i know that many
parents
particularly those who have premature
and sick babies feel that the current
system isn't working well for them and
that's why i can tell my honourable
friend we will legislate to allow
parents of children in neonatal care to
take extended leave details of this
policy were published last year and we
will bring forward the legislation as
soon as possible we now come to the
leader of the opposition kirsten
thank you mr speaker can i pay tribute
to ernie ross a formidable campaigner
who served this place in his
constituents with great distinction for
three decades
mr speaker i will pay my respects and
tribute to james brokenshire immediately
after this prime minister's questions
can i thank the whole house for the way
the tributes to sir david were handled
on monday
we saw the best of this house and i want
to see if we can use that collaborative
spirit
to make progress on one of the issues
that was raised on monday tackling
violent extremism
it's three years since the government
promised an online safety bill
but it's not yet before the house
meanwhile the damage caused by harmful
content online is worse than ever
dangerous algorithms on facebook and
instagram
and hope not have shown me an example of
violent islamism
and far-right
propaganda on tick-tock
what i was shown has been reported to
the moderators
but it stayed online because apparently
it didn't contravene the guidelines
after i find that hard to believe
so will the prime minister build on the
desire shown by this house on monday to
get things done and commit to bring
forward the second reading of the online
safety bill by the end of this calendar
year
if he does
we'll support it
prime minister uh mr speaker i thank the
right honourable gentleman for the
spirit in which he has approached this
issue and i echo what he says about the
need for cooperation across the house
because the safety of of mps indeed of
all uh public servants everybody who
engages with the public is of vital
importance and uh the online safety bill
is of of huge importance to uh is one of
the most important tools in our armory
and what we're doing is ensuring that we
crack down on uh companies that promote
illegal and uh and dangerous content and
we'll be
toughening up those provisions but mr
speaker what we are also going to do is
ensure that the online safety bill does
complete uh its uh its stages uh before
this house uh before uh before christmas
and i'm delighted or rather that we do
bring forward uh the uh bring it forward
before christmas in the way that he uh
the way that he suggests and i'm
delighted mr speaker that he is uh
offering his support and uh and we look
forward to that
kirsten
thank you mr speaker i thank the prime
minister i think from that um this isn't
a challenge it's to clarify that the
pre-legislative scrutiny will be
finished um before in early december uh
and that the second reading could i
think be before at the end of this
calendar year
but we do need to get on with this
telegram has been described as the app
of choice for extremists
and mr speaker if you can believe it if
the house can believe it
as we were paying tribute to sir david
on monday
telegram users could access
videos of murders
and violent threats against politicians
the lgbt community women and jews as we
were paying our respects
some of these posts are illegal
all of them are
harmful and
hope not hate and the board of deputies
have said that telegram has in their
words facilitated and nurtured a
subculture that cheerleads for
terrorists
tough sanctions are clearly needed yet
under the government's current proposals
directors of platforms failing to crack
down on extremism would still not face
criminal sanctions
why is that
prime minister mr speaker this is this
government that brought forward an
online uh harms bill mr speaker he's
heard uh it's he's heard what i've said
he's heard what i've said about uh
about the second reading before
christmas and you know in the collegiate
spirit in which uh he he announced his
uh he began his questioning i can tell
him that we will uh continue to uh look
at ways in which we can toughen up those
provisions and to come down hard on
those who irresponsibly allow uh
dangerous and extremist content uh to
permeate the internet but mr speaker uh
i i'm delighted that uh he's taking this
this new uh tough line and i very much
hope uh that he can be that he will get
uh the rest of his party in the lobbies
with us to join him
mr speaker i did start in the collegiate
spirit and i'll continue in a collegiate
spirit because i listened hard to what
was being said on the opposite benches
on monday about the concerns about this
issue
and we do need
to recognize the measures in the bill
but we do need tough and effective
sanctions and that means criminal
sanctions and that does matter mr
speaker
it is frankly beyond belief that as the
mirror reported yesterday
40 hours of hateful content from anjem
choudary could be easily accessed online
the prime minister and the government
could stop this by making it clear
that directors of companies are
criminally liable for failing to tackle
this type of material on their site
we don't need to delay so in the
collaborative spirit we saw in this
house on monday will the prime minister
commit to taking this away
looking at it again and working with all
of us to strengthen his proposed
legislation
i've already said that we're willing to
uh look at anything to strengthen the
legislation i've said that we're willing
to uh bring it forward and we will bring
it forward to second reading before
christmas and yes of course mr speaker
uh we will have criminal sanctions uh
with tough sentences uh for those who
are responsible for allowing this foul
content to permeate the internet mr
speaker but what we hope for also is
that no matter how tough the proposals
we produce that the honor of the
opposition will support it
mr speaker we're making progress we've
got the second reading committed to
before christmas that is a good thing
and i think the prime minister is now
committed to criminal sanctions at the
moment they're a fallback position
um at the discretion of the minister
they should be in my view on the face of
the bill as the automatic default for
the failure now if we're making progress
on that then we're beginning to address
some of the issues that were identified
across the house on monday
can i turn to the um report the
commission for countering extremism
which was set up in the wake of the
horrific manchester bombings
eight months ago that commission made
recommendations to plug gaps in existing
legislation and strategy
gaps that extremists have been able to
exploit and are continuing to exploit
yet sir mark rowley formerly head of our
counter terrorism policing who led on
those recommendations said just this
week
i've had no feedback from the home
office on their plans in relation to our
report on the absence of a coherent
legal framework to tackle hateful
extremism given the seriousness of the
matter and the clear need for action
why has the government not responded to
this important work and will the prime
minister now commit to act swiftly on
the commission's recommendations
prime minister mr speaker the government
to my right on my friend the home
secretary works with all parties to
tackle violent extremism and the uk has
one of the strongest counter-terrorism
and counter-extremism uh systems in the
world as a consequence of which we have
foiled 31 terrorist plots since 2017.
and i pay tribute to the work of of sir
mark rowley with whom i worked extremely
closely while i was in london and
all those who are involved in foiling
those terrorist pots and i can uh tell
you mr speaker that they will receive
the complete support of this house and
and of this this government and nor will
we allow them to be released of those
who are convicted to be released early
from prison mr speaker because that was
one of the most important things this
government passed and which that party
opposed
pierstama
really uh uh
take this either we take this seriously
and i'm taking my lead from those on the
opposite benches on monday and what they
were saying about the need to tackle
this either we take it seriously and go
forward together or we do a disservice
to those that we pay tribute to
there are clearly problems
there are clearly problems with the
government's counter extremism strategy
internet users are increasingly likely
to come across extremist content online
the government's own independent
reviewer has said that there is no
evidence that the government's key
de-radicalization program is effective
that's the government's independent
reviewer saying that and we've seen a
spate of loan attack killings with the
perpetrator invariably radicalized
online
we all want to stop this across this
house but at the moment things are
getting worse not better so what urgent
plans does the prime minister have to
fix these glaring problems
[Music]
prime minister mr speaker i'm more i'm
all in favor of uh collegiate and
cooperative uh approach and and and then
in which case i think it would be a fine
thing if the uh opposition would
withdraw their opposition to our
measures to stop the early release of of
serious extremist and violent offenders
that's all that's all i'm trying to say
in a clinically intercollegiate approach
and i'm i'm i'm sure that that is what
the people of this country will wish to
see uh but we will continue to do
everything that we can to strengthen our
counter-terrorism
operation and to support all those who
are involved in keeping us safe and uh
obviously it is too early to draw any
particular conclusions from the
appalling killing of our of our
colleague but we will draw all relevant
conclusions from that investigation
thank you mr speaker the inescapable
desire of this house on monday to
finally clamp down on the extremism the
hate and the abuse that festers online
is incredibly welcome
but closing down anonymous accounts
would not have prevented the murder of
joe cox
nor of pc keith palmer
and although we don't know the full
circumstances surrounding his death
nor would it have saved sir david
if we're to get serious about stopping
violent attacks
we need to stop online spaces being safe
spaces for terrorists
we need to ensure that unaccountable
arrogant social media companies take
responsibility for their platforms
we need to end the delays get on with
the legislation and clean out the
cesspit once and for all
mr speaker i've prosecuted terrorists
and i've prosecuted extremists i've
worked with mark and others
dozens of labour mps have worked hard on
tackling social media companies on these
issues
i started collegiately and i'll continue
collegiately
we know what it takes we can help so
will the prime minister now capture the
spirit that we've seen this week and
agree to work with us on a cross-party
basis so we can tackle violent extremism
and it's enablers together
mr speaker i'm i'm i'm delighted to uh
to join the uh right honourable
gentleman in uh committing to tackle
tackling online harms uh together to
tackling violent extremism together and
that that is what uh the government is
doing and that's why we brought forward
the online harms bill uh that's why
we're investing uh record sums in
tackling counter-terrorism uh but mr
speaker
i must say that what i think the whole
country in the whole house would
certainly want to see in addition in
addition if i can say this to the to the
right honourable gentleman in
a collegiate spirit in addition is a
commitment uh by the labour party in
future to support measures and not to
allow the early release of those
terrorists and those who are convicted
of those offenses from prison and i if
you could hear that from the labor party
i think it would be a fine thing crispy
blood
mr speaker knowing my right honourable
friend's commitment to uk bioscience and
his understanding of the exciting
potential for improving mental health
treatments for conditions such as
depression trauma and addiction
will he cut through the current barriers
to research into psilocybin and similar
compounds so the british public receive
and british science research
and british pharmaceutical companies
enable the potential treatments into
these most debilitating conditions to be
delivered at the earliest possible
opportunity prime minister i thank my
honorable friend i know who has a very
active interest in this in this area
what i can say to him is that we will
consider the advisory council on the
misuse of drugs uh recent advice on on
reducing barriers to research uh with uh
controlled drugs such as the one he uh
describes and we'll be getting back to
him as soon as possible
we now come to the leader of the snp ian
blackford
thank you mr speaker and can i join with
the leader of the opposition in sending
condolences to the family of emily ross
mr speaker in 11 short days world
leaders will gather in glasgow for cop
26.
this is our best chance and very likely
our last chance to confront the climate
emergency faced by our planet that is
why
it was such a devastating blow that on
the eve of court 26 this uk government
rejected the scottish clusters bid to
contract one status for carbon capture
storage today's present journal has said
there is no valid reason and no
acceptable excuse for this decision and
have called for a u-turn on this
colossal mistake immediately we know
this decision wasn't made on technicolor
logical grounds this devastating
decision was purely political scotland's
northeast was promised this investment
in 2014 it is a promise that has been
broken time and time again so mr speaker
will the prime minister finally live up
to those promises or that is simply not
worth the tory election leaflets that
they are written on
prime minister uh mr speaker we remain
absolutely committed to
helping uh industrial customers to
decarbonize across uh the whole of the
country and of course including scotland
and uh i i know that the yeah i know
that there was disappointment about the
acorn uh bid in in aberdeen and that's
why it has been selected as a reserve
cluster mr speaker but there could be no
more vivid testimony to this
government's commitment uh to scotland
or indeed to fighting climate change
that the whole world is about to come to
scotland mr speaker to look at what
scotland is doing to help tackle climate
change and i congratulate the people of
scotland on their efforts
in blackfood mr speaker people across
scotland are looking for answers today
and they're getting none
all they see is yet another tory broken
promise it's bad enough that this uk
government is holding back captioned
culture in scotland but across the board
they are proving an active barrier to
renewable energy opportunities
tidal stream energy has the potential to
generate 20
of uk generation capacity exactly the
same prime minister as nuclear all this
industry needs is a ring fence budget of
71 million pounds a drop in the ocean
compared to the 23 billion pounds that
this government is throwing at the
nuclear plant
but the uk government are failing to
give this support threatening
shovel-ready projects like meijin in the
north of scotland so at the very least
today prime minister stand up and
guarantee a ring fence budget for tidal
stream energy and save this renewable
industry from being lost overseas
prime minister well mr speaker actually
i you know i i congratulate uh the right
honourable gentleman raising uh title
and he's absolutely right i've seen the
the the amazing uh projects that are
that are underway and we're certainly
we're we're looking at uh at final we're
putting huge sums i think the house uh
will acknowledge into clean green energy
generation and he's far too gloomy uh mr
speaker about the prospects of of acorn
in uh in aberdeen i think he needs to be
a seeds with an unaccustomed spirit of
optimism uh because because actually uh
the acor the acorn the acorn project
still has strong potential and that's
why it's been selected as a reserve
cluster and he should keep hope alive mr
speaker rather than uh spreading gloom
in the way that he dies
thank you mr speaker it's always a
pleasure to follow the honourable
gentleman and the new quiet man of
british politics
continue
to
the weekend before
the weekend before last i went to see
with the brixton trawlers and bricks and
fish market is now turning over 1.4
million pounds a week they're looking
forward to their share of the leveling
up fund but they're also looking forward
to the previously announced hundred
million pound fisheries and seafood
scheme when will we be seeing that
pillar two and three launch and will the
prime minister reaffirm his commitment
to our coastal communities and our
fishing sector
i thank my honourable friend for what
he's doing for the for for fishing and
for and for for the coastal communities
and for brixton in particular i
understand the fish market in brixton
was outstandingly successful uh the
other day and what we're going to do is
make sure that we continue to support uh
in the seafood business across the the
country and the scheme has approved
funding in brixton and salcombe and in
dartmouth mr speaker and a further 100
million pounds is being made available
through the uk seafood fund to support
our fisheries
if cop 26 is to be successful
people must be at the heart of our net
zero mission
for too long the uk economy has left too
many people behind
with wealth and investment hoarded in
the southeast of england
devolving powers over the crown estate
would bring
half a billion pounds worth of offshore
wind and tidal stream potential under
welsh control
assets of course currently controlled by
westminster scotland meanwhile already
has these powers
will he support my bill to devolve the
management of the crown estate to wales
prime minister uh well uh mr speaker as
she already knows the crime stake works
closely with the welsh government and
with natural resources in wales and i
i'm sorry to have to tell her that uh my
view is at the crown estate in wales uh
the devolution of the crown estate in
wales would fragment the market uh
complicate uh existing processes and
make it more difficult uh for wales as
well as the whole of the uk to move
forward to next zero brendan's locksmith
yeah
thank you mr speaker delivering new
homes is key to levelling up as is
putting that power in the hands of local
people and making sure we build the
right number in the right places but my
constituents especially in thieves dale
and aldsall are concerned about
over-intensive developments in our local
plant
well the prime minister confirmed that
the minimum housing requirement for
basic law is 48
and not the 10 000 as claimed by the
labour on council
well mr speaker i'm not surprised to say
that my honourable friend is completely
right
and uh
and this government is uh is determined
to give the people of this country the
the homes that they need we're building
record numbers of homes but we owe it to
uh to our kinder gentler politics mr
speaker to uh to be accurate about what
is going on in our constituencies and
this government does not set local
housing uh targets and i understand that
the draft basic law local plan is
subject uh to consultation i would
encourage him and his constituents to
make their views known
yeah mr speaker tomorrow at 2 50 p.m my
constituency will fall silent as we mark
exactly 50 years since scotland's
largest peacetime explosion ripped
through clarkston toll in eastern
prussia
ten shops were demolished by the
ignition of gas which had escaped from a
fractured gas main beneath the shops a
passing bus was caught up in the blast
22 people died mostly women and over 100
were injured
tomorrow 50 years on the community and
families will come together for a
memorial service
so will the prime minister join me in
acknowledging the terrible losses that
many families locally suffered and the
continuing sorrow in the community and
in reflecting that the victims of the
clarkson disaster must never be
forgotten
mr speaker i thank the honourable lady
for for raising this uh anniversary and
uh she's right to commemorate the
victims of the clarkson disaster and uh
our thoughts and our condolences
continue to be with uh the families of
those who who lost uh lost loved ones
and of course we must do everything in
our power to make sure that no such a
tragedy is repeated robinson thank you
mr speaker the failings of greater
manchester police which have led to it
being placed in special measures are
well documented including the failure to
record 80 000 crimes in a single year
and those included domestic violence and
sexual offenses but it's particularly
important that the force addresses what
the rece what a recent manchester
evening news investigation called its
culture of denial and secrecy after the
horrific murder of sarah everard it's
crucial that we tackle the cover-up
culture will my right honourable friend
the prime minister therefore join me in
calling for greater manchester police to
urgently review its internal culture and
also will he consider reforming the law
on whistleblowing so people in greater
manchester police and other
organizations can speak up against
wrongdoing in confidence
yes mr speaker it's vital that people
should uh have the confidence to speak
up against wrongdoing wherever they find
it particularly of course in the in the
police i do believe that the people of
uh greater manchester deserve better i i
support and agree with what my
honourable friend says i would just say
one thing mr speaker it is the
responsibility of the mayor of greater
manchester uh to ensure that the uh the
police force acts uh not a point that i
hope will be taken up on the benches
opposite uh to ensure that the police
force act swiftly and decisively to
address the failures that his
constituents are currently finding
thank you mr speaker
i would like to join colleagues in
paying tribute to the honourable member
for southampton sea
he was a good friend
and an esteemed parliamentarian
i also wish to pay tribute to the right
honorable member for old baxley and
he
served this house and country as
seriously and will be missed by members
across the house mr speaker
heating bills
food shops and fuel costs are all rising
at a staggering speed
this winter
millions of families on universal credit
will be forced to choose between eating
or heating
given the prices and living costs we are
now facing
will the prime minister reconsider
his scrapping of the universal credit
uplift
and reinstate
the 20 pounds a week lifeline he has
just taken away
mr speaker what we're doing is ensuring
that uh we keep costs of heating down
with the the the price cap but we put
the we put the uh we put we've increased
the winter uh the warm heat the warm
homes allowance uh by 150 150 pounds for
780 000 uh homes and we've just given
local councils another half billion to
help uh poorer families uh over uh over
the winter but the most important thing
that's happening mr speaker in this
country is that wages are going up and
uh there is a there is a huge jobs boom
now in this country thanks to the
policies that this government has
pursued bob blackman thank you mr
speaker i'm sure my right honourable
friend would agree with me that homeless
people should be assisted or not
arrested
the review of the repeal of the vacancy
act of 1824 has now been concluded
does my rightful friend agree with me
therefore that is now time that the
amendments to the police crime
sentencing and courts bill which are
being considered in the other place
should be adopted so that we can consign
the vacancy act to the history books
forever but give the police the powers
they need to combat trespass aggressive
begging and other anti-social behavior
uh mr speaker my honorable friend is a
passionate campaigner on this issue and
he he he's done a lot of of good things
in this area no one should be
criminalized simply of having nowhere to
live and i think the time has come to
reconsider the vagrancy act mr speaker
but also to redouble our efforts uh to
fight homelessness as i think we've done
successfully over the pandemic but must
continue to do inflection
thank you mr speaker university
hospital's coventry and warwickshire nhs
trust has dealt with more than 600
attacks on staff during the pandemic
to deter further attacks staff in the
hospital's a e department are now
wearing body cameras
it simply isn't right that doctors and
nurses should have to go to such lengths
just to feel safe at work
will the prime minister join me in
condemning those abhorrent attacks and
say what immediate steps he will take to
better protect our nhs heroes as they go
about their work treating patients and
saving lives
uh mr speaker i joined the honourable
lady opposite absolutely in condemning
attacks on all public uh servants and
particularly on nhs staff who are who
are trying to to save people and and and
and help people in in their life and uh
what we are what we are doing what we've
already done is to toughen the sentences
for those who assault or or who or who
harass public servants
we now come to charles barlow final
question
given the recent tragic circumstances
there's inevitably been a focus on the
security of members and their staff
mr speaker one aspect that is often
overlooked
is the fact that it is our staff
who are on the front line
in receiving the abusive emails and
correspondence
and they take the hostile phone calls
they are private citizens
simply trying to earn a living to put
food on the table and pay for their rent
or their mortgage
yet they are caught up
in this vicious cycle of venom
and abuse that is directed towards us
would my right honourable friend the
prime minister take this opportunity
to acknowledge the fantastic work that
our staff do
and give them the credit that they so
rightly deserve
prime minister
mr speaker i think that uh my right
honourable friend spoke there for the
entire house of commons because uh we
all know
that it is our staff our our caseworkers
our office managers uh who are so often
uh in the front line who have to deal uh
with anger uh with intemperate behavior
and with abuse and they cope with it
magnificently we all know that the risks
the risks that they run in their daily
lives and indeed mr speaker we've seen
how some house of common staff have paid
for that for that for their sacrifice in
even with their lives and mr speaker i
thoroughly echo and support and concur
with what my honourable friend has said
order
i said on monday that the house would
have an opportunity to pay tribute and
remember our friend and colleague james
brokenshire
i would like to do so by inviting
members to join me in a minute silence
in memory of james can we all please
stop
thank
you james was a politician who commanded
affection and respect from colleagues no
matter which party they represented
in a parliamentary career spanning 16
years
james's contribution to public life was
immense
he served in successes governments
ministerial roles across the home office
as well as serving as secretary of state
for northern ireland and later a
secretary of state for housing
communities and local government
his commitment to serving his
constituents in old bexley and sidcup
was also obvious to anybody who knew him
i will always remember james for his
positivity his good sense of humor and
film for being one of the most friendly
thoughtful
well-liked in the house of commons
his passing is profound lost to us all
our thoughts go out to his wife kathy
and the three children who were here
today to watch our tributes so i just
want to remind people the family are
with us and it is great that they've
turned up today and thank you
order we've now come to the point where
we start with the prime minister's
learning statement tributes prime
minister
thank you mr speaker i
i'm sure the whole house will join me in
uh and and you in expressing our deep
sorrow over the tragically early death
of james brokenshire
and in sending our heartfelt heartfelt
condolences to his wife kathy
and their three children
sophie gemma and ben
who with us today
for the loss of a beloved husband and
father
the many tributes paid to james
a testament to the affection respect and
esteem
in which he is remembered and his skill
as an able and effective politician
who served his country under three prime
ministers in some of the most sensitive
and demanding positions in government
i worked closely with james for the
first time when i was mayor of london
and he was the honourable member for
horn church and then for old bexley and
sid cup
and i saw how much he cared for the
interests of his constituents always
taking the time to stop and talk to
people and listen to what they had to
say
unflappable
earnest
sincere
and he brought those same
down-to-earth qualities into other areas
of his life
being photographed baking cakes in his
kitchen
starting a twitter frenzy on the vital
question of whether he owned two ovens
or four
and once when challenged by an
interviewer to choose between south end
or the south of france his reply was
swift
south end i'm an essex boy and proud of
my roots and he would be delighted to
know that his birthplace has now
achieved city status
in tribute to his friend sir david amos
whose campaign he supported
but it was james's diligence
composure and experience as a lawyer
steeped in the art of negotiating last
minute deals that proved so valuable
to the government
he held five ministerial jobs including
two in cabinet the secretary of state
for northern ireland and for housing
communities and local government and
every one of them was fraught with traps
for the unwary and opportunities for
error
the fact that he improved his reputation
in each post shows that we've lost an
astute politician
of rare ability
james served with particular distinction
in the home office
as security and immigration minister
where he was fondly known by civil
servants as jb
oh good they would say we've got jb on
this one and he often
reflected that working at the home
office was to be on the receiving end of
incessant incoming fire from the media
and it usually fell to him to brave the
barrage when things got really sticky
so it's no wonder that
on his last day officials presented
james with an authentic military-grade
tin hat
during that tumultuous period which i
remember well
he kept he helped to keep our country
safe he oversaw the superb security
operation that protected the london
olympic and paralympic games in 2012.
he was central to getting rid of abu
qatada setting him packing after more
than a decade of legal wrangles
and he steered the groundbreaking modern
slavery bill through parliament giving
the police and law enforcement agencies
the power they need to combat some of
the most dangerous and repellent
criminals of all
and through all this he would help
individuals in need including taking the
time to meet people with direct
experience of government decisions and
it was after a
conversation with a homeless man in
bristol
that he acted to strengthen the rights
of tenants and give them a greater sense
of security in their homes
we can only imagine
how much more good he would have done
if he had been given the chance
james was in the prime of his life
with a huge amount still
to offer his country
and it was the cruelest of fates that he
a non-smoker should have been struck
down by lung cancer
his tenacious
fight
showed the depths of his his courage and
his character
after his first bite with the disease as
colleagues will remember he was back in
this house within weeks
serving in government and helping his
constituents
he campaigned for better lung cancer
screening becoming the first honourable
member to secure a debate on this issue
in the house
he sought
to dispel the stigma and misperceptions
around the disease and when james fell
sick again earlier this year
even in the midst of his ordeal he
summoned the strength to record a video
message encouraging others to seek help
and early treatment
every member of this house
willed him then
to pull through
but sadly
it was not to be
james
was a gentleman politician
and i hope my right honourable friend
the member for maidenhead will allow me
to quote her words
that politics and parliament would be
the better
if there were more people of his caliber
involved
and politics and parliament are the
weaker
for his loss
i could not agree more
james's
absence will be sorely felt in this
house
in the great departments
where he served
and by all the people whose lives he
touched
we come to the leader of the opposition
kirsten yeah
thank you mr speaker
one of the first things i learned when i
arrived in this house was that there are
not many glamorous roles in opposition
no one gives you a guidebook on how to
do these jobs you're appointed and off
you go
of course you can ask older wiser heads
you can appoint excellent staff but
generally
you're on your own
there's one little known exception to
this rule
a secret in westminster
and that is when you shadow a government
minister
of such decency
courtesy
and sense of fair play
that they reach out across the divide
and provide helpful pointers
you're not on your own
and so it was for me
when as a new mp in 2015 i was appointed
a shadow immigration minister
i shadowed james brokenshire
i have to admit i was unprepared for the
vagaries of the bill committee rules
even years in the criminal justice
system
had not prepared me for the complexities
of the arkham
processes
but in one of my first outings in the
bill committee i almost missed my cue to
make my argument now some of you would
see that as a blessing
but james was far too decent for that he
wouldn't take advantage he went out of
his way
to ensure not only that i was heard but
i was heard with respect
and that was the characteristic that was
the character that was james and from
that day in 2015
we forged a friendship
which lasted until his untimely death
and on these benches
my story is not an unusual story because
anyone who got to know james who worked
with him or against him
ended up respecting him
and liking him
and willing him to pull through
at the time i got to know james he was
widely seen as an upcoming star of this
house
as the prime minister has said he'd
already played a key role
in the creation of the modern slavery
act
and it began to carve out a reputation
as an unassuming but very effective
minister
he was a party leader's dream
happy to roll up his sleeves do the
tough jobs with little regard for
self-promotion
but advancing your career in any walk of
life isn't just about hard work and
talent although james had those in
abundance
it's about who you are
and it was little surprise when james
got a full role in the cabinet
first as northern ireland secretary and
then as community secretary
and he brought his calm and understated
manner
his effectiveness
and his respect for others to both roles
and he will be long remembered for it
when someone is taken as young as james
was
by a cruel disease like cancer
there is an inevitable sense that they
were robbed of fulfilling their
potential
and james was he had achieved so much
but i strongly believe we all strongly
believe that he had so much more to
give
characteristically right to the end he
was campaigning to remove the stigma
from lung cancer
in order to improve the lives of others
a cause i hope this house continues to
champion in his memory
james's wife and young family are with
us here today
we send our condolences
and if i may say so
they should be very proud
of their husband
and father
and they should know that across these
this house on all of these benches
he commanded enormous respect and good
will
amongst his constituents he was very
well liked
he was a friend to many of us across
this house
including me
our politics is poorer without him
we will miss him
but we will all ensure
that his memory lives on
thank you mr speaker follow the host
pizza peter bottom
on the 30th of april 2018
mr speaker said it must be enormous fun
shave broken shower at meal time
that was when james said he used to
discuss local government with his father
when his father was the chief executive
in the borough i then served
james
in that column 10
used seven words to describe his father
as having a focus and a dedication as a
public servant
james learned that lesson
he also said
that private leaseholders should not be
have the costs of fire remediation
passed on to them
i think fulfilling his dedication as
housing minister
i invite the chancellor and the prime
minister discussed how that can be
fulfilled because at the moment those
costs are being passed on to those
disorders
we now come to the leader of the smp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker i think we all
share
the real sense of sadness that
in the space of two days we are meeting
again to pay tribute to another deceased
colleague
two colleagues taken in very different
circumstances
but both taken
well before their time
mr speaker
james brokenshire was a young man who
clearly
had so much more to give
that is what must be so tragic for his
colleagues and friends on the government
benches and we are all very
conscious and compassionate to the pain
that they must be feeling this week
but most especially
we think of
james's young family on behalf of these
benches our thoughts and prayers are are
with his wife katherine his son ben and
his daughters sophie and gemma
it is important to mark the manner in
which that family have dealt with their
grief but i know
that they have been deeply involved in
remarkable fundraising efforts since
james's untimely death
that spirit that the family has shown
since his death is no doubt a tribute to
the way in which james himself
dealt with his illness
but i think all of us across this house
looked on with deep admiration and oh
the sheer bravery he showed well bravely
battling against the cancer that sadly
ultimately took his life
my own experience and engagement with
james was mainly when he was the
minister at the home office
when he was an immigration minister i
remember dealing with james in some
detail
on a particular case concerning a family
in the highlands who were being
threatened with deportation
and i'm glad to say mr speaker that
after some
considerable effort from all involved
that the family eventually got the
resolution that they desperately needed
i know from colleagues in northern
ireland as well that although his time
there came at a politically delicate and
difficult period he remained on very
good terms with all the parties during
his period the secretary of state
i think it's fair to say
that that in itself is no mean feat for
any british secretary of state that
serves there
and i can only think that it was because
of the way that he approached people
and the way that he approached his work
because
it has been very rightly said
that there wasn't a man interested in
the insubstantial distractions of
politics he quietly got on with his job
he was above all else
diligent and determined
the mark of a man and our memory of him
will be of a dedicated minister a loyal
friend and a dedicated father
james
battled to the very end against his
cancer
now
that his battle is over
may rest in peace god bless you
james theresa may
thank you mr speaker
i had the enormous privilege of working
with james brokenshire
in government first of all for six years
in the home office and then in his roles
as secretary of state for northern
ireland and communities secretary
james was a remarkable man
he was an outstanding minister
a great constituency member of
parliament
and a true friend
words have been used by others such as
diligent
hard-working and he was both of those
as a minister he was assiduous in
dealing with the briefs that he was that
he read
he was thoughtful in his consideration
of the issues and careful in his
decision-making that is what you want
from a government minister
he gave his time and effort because he
understood the importance of the
decisions he was making
he cared about people
and he cared about the work he was doing
and that came through in all the
decisions he made and in the way in
which he reached out across this house
to ensure
that those decisions were the right ones
so he was an outstanding minister but he
was also a very good constituency mp
very often uh if you try to contact a
minister on a friday they're in their
office but actually james more often
than not was in his constituency
and that's what he understood
all of us are here because our
constituents have placed us here and
anybody who is fortunate enough to
become a government minister is only
there because their constituents have
placed them here and we should never
forget that is the basis of our being
here and our
responsibilities he was a true friend if
from what i've said and what others have
said you get the impression that james
was just a hard-working workaholic
james was great fun
evenings with kathy and james were
evenings of fun and laughter
and he was also a loving family man
and i remember when
he had been diagnosed first diagnosed
with his lung cancer
and he was stepping down from government
his first thought to me was about the
impact it would have on kathy and the
family
he was that loving family man he was out
there in his constituency and he great
gave dedicated public service to this
country
the government is the poorer for his
loss
this parliament is the poorer for his
loss
and our country is the poorer for his
loss
well tribute to jane's
tribute to james brokenshire there from
uh theresa may the prime minister who
worked with him uh most closely uh
really reflecting a pretty somber mood
in prime minister's questions today of
course following the killing of david
amos as well uh last week
and a new approach taken to prime
minister's questions what zakir starmer
called the collegiate spirit uh with me
our political led to beth rigby and
it was an effective session but not what
we've got used to and at one point uh
secure said i really don't want to
descend to this kind of knockout knock
about
yeah it's interesting because remember
on monday when mps talked about having
more consensus across the house
rupert hook ended that session saying we
need to be less cross and more cross
party that was how she a labour mp kind
of closed the session uh in those
tributes to sir david amos and then um
um
kirsten we're really picking up on that
saying
let's try and see what we can do in
terms of the online harms bill how do we
toughen it up putting forward actual
suggestions of trying to improve uh the
bill to the prime minister and really
kind of getting on the front foot but
not in an
aggressive way
or an adversarial or a polarized way but
trying to build cross-party consensus i
have to say i don't think boris johnson
was necessarily that comfortable that
and he did try a bit of knockabout as he
tried to criticize labour for not
supporting uh the police in bill now he
said that was you're trying to being
opposed to stronger sentences for
terrorists of course it's a massive bill
with lots of pieces of legislation in it
some of which labour are opposed to and
and and kirsten said i'm not engaging in
that knock about it somewhat took the
wind out of the pm sales but is it going
to stick is that how we're going to see
people we shall see beth thank you very
much indeed one thing they didn't talk
about was covid but we are going to have
a news conference on that subject from
the health secretary at 5 this evening
stay with sky news
[Music]
foreign